Sonic Frontiers marks a bold New
Direction for this series meshing
traditional Sonic action with an
open-ended approach to progression and
exploration across its semi-open World
from the moment it was first revealed it
was clear that Sonic Frontiers is quite
unlike any of its predecessors Sonic's
3D Adventures had been more Miss than
hit throughout the blue Hedgehog's
31-year existence for every Sonic
Generations there's been a sonic boom or
Sonic 06 leaving behind a bitter taste
and further diluting the Speedy mascots
appeal each new game is offered some
variation on the Sonic formula hoping to
catch lightning in a bottle and finally
give the series a consistent Direction
moving forward but none have succeeded
at least until now Sonic Frontiers is
that game
[Music]
foreign it certainly has its flaws and
still maintains many of the familiar
elements you'd expect to find in a game
starring the eponymous Hedgehog but it's
in the difference where Sonic Frontier
stands out and occasionally excels
making it the best 3D Sonic game in more
than a decade the biggest and most
notable change is the shift to a
semi-open world Sega calls Frontiers
open Zone meaning the game is split into
multiple islands that Sonic is free to
explore each Zone has its own aesthetic
from verdant Rolling Hills to arid
desert Plains and a simmering volcanic
island floating above the clouds meshing
together Natural Beauty with ancient
alien temples grind rails and bounce
pads it's a curious amalgamation but one
that works well enough within the game
sci-fi conceit the environments are also
part of a striking tonal ship for the
series The vibrant primary colors of
classic Sonic's levels like Green Hill
Zone have been replaced by a color
palette that's low on saturation and
high-end pastel Hues the obvious this
inspiration here is the Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild not just in the way
frontier's looks but in its use of music
and the shift to open-ended World design
it doesn't play anything like Link's
five-year-old Adventure but you can see
how Sonic team was influenced by it
throughout progression across each
island adheres to the same basic
gameplay Loop you defeat many bosses to
collect cogs use these to open up
cyberspace levels complete challenges
Within These more traditional Sonic
stages turn valkies and then use these
to unlock Chaos Emeralds so you can
transform into Supersonic and defeat
each Island's Titan in a massive boss
battle along the way you'll discover
bite-sized challenges that reveal more
of the map and reward you with upgrade
items and short platforming sections
that Grant you the memory tokens you
need the free Sonic's friends and Propel
the story forward all of this may sound
a tad convoluted but there's a
satisfying flow to how exploration and
progression work to the point where you
don't even need to think about the
bigger picture on a moment-to-moment
basis there's an in-game map complete
with a plethora of very serious markers
but it's not something I ever felt
compelled to look at the game does a
fantastic job of gently guiding you
towards points of interest whether it's
a structure on the horizon or a set of
conveniently placed ramps and boost pads
leading to a platforming segment
advancing the story requires you to
collect a certain number of memory
tokens at different intervals but
grabbing them comes naturally while
traversing the worlds they never feel
like something you need to go out of
your way to track down the same is true
the quickfire challenges you'll find
dotted on each island these range from
short time trials to Tetris style
puzzles and each one concludes with a
few hopeful piano notes that we feel
right at home in breath of the Wild
[Music]
tedium is a potential downfall of this
formulaic approach since you're going
through the same repetitive gameplay
loop with each New Island you visit it's
not something I've felt until reaching
the fifth and final Island mainly
because the bite-sized nature of each
activity helps Stave off any monotony as
does the degree of variety that's
present in almost everything you engage
with be it enemy types environments
challenges and so on it's still not
quite enough to sustain the entire game
though and it's disappointing that it
runs out of steam toward the end combat
is infrequent but has at least been
expanded upon so you're not just using
Sonic's homing attack to lay waste to
everything in your path you start off
with a basic one button combo and a stop
attack plus you can dodge and Parry
incoming attacks gradually however
you'll begin to unlock more abilities
via frontier's skill tree you can argue
that a character like Sonic doesn't
necessarily need a skill tree and its
inclusion here does feel rather
Superfluous considering you simply
unlock every move as you progress
through the game there's no deliberate
rating over specific skills to suit a
particular playstyle so the skill tree
comes across like it was added because
that's the Contemporary thing to do even
if it doesn't quite fit the moves you
unlock are fun to use though frequently
giving you more options when engaging
enemies the first ability you gain
access to is called siloops which lets
you draw circles around your foes and
inflict damage on all of those inside
this can also be used to penetrate and
remove armor on certain enemy types
letting you finish them off with a
flurry of strikes once they're
vulnerable
there are other more flashy moves too
allowing you to fire shock waves from a
distance follow up a successful Dodge
with a zigzagging attack or Pummel
enemies with a flying kick all of these
moves are easy to pull off so you can
build up lengthy combos without much
effort this could get tiresome fairly
quickly but what makes combat enjoyable
is the variety of enemy types you'll
encounter you forces you to think about
how you're going to defeat them and this
is especially true when facing off
against one of the many Guardians
roaming each island there are dozen of
these mini bosses all with
self-explanatory names like spider tank
and a Sumo for the most part these
battles are Grand in their spectacle and
scale pitting Sonic against huge foes
that dwarf his tiny frame but their
quality is uneven at their best you'll
be grinding around circular discs while
avoiding obstacles to reach a weak point
or bouncing off the fences of an
enclosed cage to generate momentum and
send the guardian karining into an
electrified Hazard but others are
protracted designed around dual
mechanics and a flimsy lock-on system
targeting enemies only works at
extremely close range despite the fact
you're regularly fighting in open areas
this makes it difficult to keep an enemy
in sight as you close the distance and
attempt to avoid the many projectiles
they're firing your way at times you'll
also need to Target specific body parts
but this is is another lesson in
frustration as you fight against
frontier's cumbersome lock-on
cyberspace levels similarly vary in
quality you'll find teleportation points
scattered across each island that
transport you to these short traditional
Sonic stages they run the gamut of
familiar styles with some geared towards
hitting every boost pad While others are
grind heavy or shift the perspective to
2D with a focus on more deliberate
platforming readability in the latter is
difficult however especially since the
camera is zoomed in tight and Sonic's
floating movement and imprecise jumping
aren't particularly conducive to
enjoyable platforming you can finish
most of these cyberspace levels in a
minute or two but their tourist length
does lend itself to how replayable they
are each level has optional sub
challenges for you to complete with one
of them rewarding you for completing a
Level under the s-rank time limit I
spent plenty of time going back to find
the optimal route through a stage to
complete it as fast as possible and
doing so feels like a well-earned
victory it's disappointing that there
isn't more variety from a visual
standpoint though most of the cyberspace
levels pay homage to Classic stages from
Sonic's past with themes based around
the likes of Green Hill Zone chemical
plant zone and radical highway but it
doesn't really deviate so levels near
the end of the game still look the same
as those at the start running around at
the speed of sound might be a mantra of
the fleet-footed Hedgehog but Sonic
Frontiers is at its best when you're
given time to Simply explore the music
is calming and also solemn at times even
if it knows when to burst into life with
the punk rock energy and there's even a
fishing minigame that lets you earn
rewards while slowing down the pace a
step further it's easy to fall into a
Zen like flow as you Traverse each
island rattling off objectives as you
happen upon them there are frustrations
that arise and break the flow whether
it's a middling mini boss or struggle
with Sonic's floaty movement and it's a
big departure from what Sonic fans are
used to I am fully on board with this
new Direction though Sonic Adventure set
the template for the last 24 years of 3D
Sonic games and I'm hopeful Frontiers
will do the same for the Next Generation
it has its flaws and there's definite
room for improvements but the spiky
mascot is finally moving in the right
direction